[Music]
the princess cesarok the daughter of the
high king of the kargish lands
at first in the sixth earth sea novel by
ursula k leguin the other wind appears
to be just something like a pawn or even
just a piece in a game that is being
played between the two kings the high
king of the kargish lands who now is
willing to enter into negotiations with
the king lebanon of the rest of earthsea
and it's proposed that he ought to he
lebanon ought to give this kargish
princess the ring of peace that is to
marry her and thereby become the
son-in-law of the high king and lebanon
really doesn't like this he feels as is
as if he's being played and part of it
is due to the fact that
the kargish princess seems totally
out of place within the court of havnor
she's dressed from head to toe in a red
veil nobody can actually see her she
doesn't know any of the language and so
she's kind of a cipher she's a
symbol at best of things and tennar can
talk with her because tenor of course is
cargish
and she tells lebanon what's going on
and so one of the key themes
in the development of this character is
going to be fear on the one hand and
courage
early on
she says she's frightened tenor said and
then lebanon says so she hides in her
tent who does she think i am
how could she know what you are he's
scowled how old is she young but a woman
i can't marry her he said with sudden
resolution i'll send her back and tenor
says a returned bride is a dishonored
woman if you send her back thole might
kill her to keep the dishonor from his
house he'll certainly consider you
intend to dishonor
him
and so
there's there's a crisis here this is
one of the third problems facing uh
lebanon and earthsea at the beginning of
the work so she's hiding behind her
veils she's in her tent when he sends
her to the river house she stays there
and we find out that she is indeed
fearful she's fearful of a number of
different things she has a conversation
with tenor and it's through these
conversations that we get to know the
princess
she's feeling afraid of the water and
seasickness because she had never
left the desert she had never gone to
the beach of the island and then
suddenly she's placed on a ship and has
to sail all the way to hovnor seasick
the entire time not actually knowing
what's going on with with herself other
than she's being sent to be you know
essentially a gift
in in a set of exchanges going on so
there's that she's also afraid of being
treated as just a
stupid woman in her own
words and you know it also perhaps is
deserving
that so she says
at one point um
i know what i am here in that big city
ahwabath where my father is i was a
stupid ignorant desert woman a feyagot
this means a veiled person the city
woman sniggered and poked each other
whenever they saw me the bare-faced
[ __ ] and here it's worse i can't
understand anybody and they can't
understand me and everything everything
is different i don't even know what the
food is it's sorcerer food it makes me
dizzy
i don't know what the taboos are there
aren't any priests to ask only sorcerer
women all black and bear-faced so this
is a big problem for her she not only
feels out of place like a tourist might
right or somebody who's just suddenly
gone to another place she doesn't
understand what anybody's saying at
first before she learns that there's
another language that she thinks they're
just making fun of her the way that the
city women had before
and so that's a central concern she's
also worried unnecessarily about being
sacrificed to dragons and we find out
that
here we go uh
as soon as tenor shows up she she says
um
here we go a tall vigorous young woman
full of emotion knocked her right off
her feet but held her up in strong arms
oh lady arja ladyara save me save me she
was crying and and tener says princess
what's wrong the princess was in tears
of terror or relief or both at once and
all tenor could understand of her
laments and please was a babble of
dragons and sacrifice
and so tenor says there are no dragons
near havnor nobody's being sacrificed
what's this all about what have you been
told
the women said the dragons were coming
and they'd sacrifice a king's daughter
and not a goat because they're sorcerers
and i was afraid and then tenor says
your women are ignorant and don't know
enough heartache to understand what
people tell them and you don't know any
heartache at all you know and then a
little bit later
uh you know uh cesarok tells her this
this story about the dragons there
at uh her at her
and she says
um
don't you have the spring sacrifice in
ottawa on tenor shook her head well
that's why i got scared you see because
it can be a human sacrifice if things
weren't going well they'd sacrifice a
king's daughter otherwise it would just
be some ordinary girl but they haven't
done that even that for a long time
nonsen not since i was little but they
haven't done that
my father defeated all the other kings
since then they've only sacrificed a
she-goat and an ewe but maybe they'll
sacrifice me here and tenor says no no
that's not what's going on the dragons
are coming to talk so don't worry about
that so that figure goes away right away
there's another fear as well that she's
going to have to work through and it has
to do with
marrying lebanon and this this is
stemming from the beliefs
that they they have
and
here we go
um
yeah the she tells this story of the the
uh
verdernan this this agreement and then
finally
um cesarok says
i have to marry him and so i will be
lost what does that mean to be lost
and tenor says why are you lost if you
marry him so here's the explanation if i
marry him i have to give him my name if
he speaks my name he steals my soul
that's what the accursed sorcerers do so
they always hide their names but if he
steals my soul i won't be able to die
i'll have to live forever without my
body a bird that can't fly and never be
reborn
and tenor says that's why you hid your
name
i gave it to you my friend
i honor the gift my friend tenor said
energetically but you can say your name
to anybody you want here they can't
steal your soul with it believe me
cesaro and you can trust him he doesn't
he won't do you any harm
the girl had caught her hesitation
and because you know tenar is actually
concerned about the fact that lebanon
has this anger towards cesarok right
but he wishes he could she said tenor my
friend i know what i am here this is
where she talks about the big city and
then she says i can see out of my veil
you know i saw his face he's very
handsome he looks like a warrior but
he's a black sorcerer and he hates me
don't say he doesn't because i know he
does and i think when he learns my name
he'll send my soul to that place forever
and tenor actually doesn't give her the
the name to lebanon right away honoring
this this somewhat uh mistaken request
but she's very worried about this she's
worried about the hostility
now things begin to change
when they decide that they're going to
have to sail to gant and tenor says you
know you really need to take cesaro or
not not cesarok but the princess along
on this and lebanon says oh no that
would be a terrible idea and there's a
little bit of a conflict there between
the two tenor
and um lebanon
and
this is this is quite important what
what happens here
he says you know she's completely
unfitted for such a journey and tenor
says i know nothing of the kind
she has no education here tenner says
something really important
she's intelligent
practical
and courageous
here you know is the first time where
she's being described not as fearful but
as courageous
she's aware of what her station requires
of her she hasn't been trained to rule
but then what can she learn boxed up
here in the river house with her
servants in some court languages to
speak the language in the first place
lebanon responds and tenner says she's
doing that i'll interpret for her when
she needs it
and
eventually he says the princess has no
place on this voyage and tahanu says
her
tenor says tahanu and irian both say she
should come with us master onyx says
that like alder of tan her being sent
here cannot be an accident
lebanon says i cannot permit it her
ignorance and experience would make her
a serious burden and i can't put her at
risk relationships with her father and
then tenor says this
in her ignorance as you call it she
showed us how to answer ged's questions
you
are as disrespectful of her as her
father is you speak of her as a mindless
thing tenor's face was pale with anger
if you're afraid to put her at risk ask
her to take it
herself
so lebanon says all right
i accept your judgment
please tell her if she wishes to come
she may do so and then tenor says no you
need to go tell her it's you who should
tell her that so he says
all right
i'll go i'll i'll ask her. and first he
says let's have her come here and then
he gets impatient he's like i'll go
there
and what happens
something that changes the dynamic and
the relationship between them
the wonderful
passage here
the breeze from the water made the veils
tremble and shimmer so that the figure
did not appear solid but delicate moving
shivering like the willow foliage it
seemed to shrink to shorten she was
making her courtesy to him he bowed to
her they both straightened up and stood
in silence
princess lebanon said with a feeling of
unreality hearing his own voice i am
here to ask you to come to roque island
she said nothing
he saw the fine red veils part in an
oval as she spread them with her hands
long fingered golden skinned hands held
apart to reveal her face in the red
shadow he could not see her features
clearly she was nearly as tall as he and
her eyes looked straight at him
my friend tenar she said say
king to see king
face and face i say yes i will
half understanding lebron
about again you honor me my lady yes she
said i honor you
he hesitated
this was different ground entirely her
ground
she stood there straight and still the
gold edging of her veils shivering her
eyes looking at him out of the shadow
tener and tahanu and ormerian agree it
would be well if the princess of the car
god lands were here were with with us on
rogue island so i ask you to come with
us to come
to roque island on ship she said and
suddenly made a little moaning plaintiff
noise
then she said
i will i will to come
he bowed he left her as he'd been taught
to leave the presence of his father the
prince
not turning his back but stepping
backwards
courageous
tenor had called her he did not
understand but he knew that he had been
in the presence of courage
all the anger that had filled him
brought him here was gone
vanished
he had not been sucked down and
suffocated but brought up short
in front of a rock a high place in clear
air
a truth
this is the first real encounter between
princess cecirac and king lebanon
and there's more yet to come but here he
realizes that he is
in the presence of courage a courage
that isn't a lack of fear
but a dealing with
fear on the voyage she
has to deal with seasickness and you
know to the extent that tenor even uh
gets a little bit ticked off with her
right and she says she's not sick
cesarok you're not sick you're afraid of
being sick get hold of yourself come out
on deck
fresh air will make all the difference
fresh air
and courage
so this is quite interesting tenna are
saying your fears are really fears of
succumbing to your fears don't let that
happen to you choose to do something
that will help you out you have to have
the courage but fresh air will also help
you cesarok then says to her
oh my friend make me courage
and tenor says you have to make it
yourself princess
come on just try it out on deck for a
minute
and they they get out on the deck this
whole idea of making yourself courage is
something important then they look and
they see irian who's having no trouble
at all and um
[Music]
cesaro says she makes herself courage ah
and then tenor said she doesn't need to
make it i think she's fearless so this
is interesting irian doesn't really
possess courage as such in the way that
these human people can because she is
courage she she just is what she is
right uh dragons are their their very
nature
human beings have to try to overcome and
deal with their fears and a little bit
later when lebanon is talking with her
she says to him
i will not to fear
and now that could be understood as just
kind of her broken heartache right i
will i i'm not going to fear but it can
also be understood as choosing as
imposing one's own will upon one's own
unruly self and saying i will not give
in to fear
and so that that's quite important
um lebanon also you know feels bad about
this and says hey can we do anything for
her is there any possibility of
helping her out and this leads to
something else where she overcomes
another one of her her worries and fears
right
so
onyx and alder and seppel consult
and they decide to give her a talisman
the princess's long-fingered hand
emerged from the red and gold veils the
wizard placed in at a queer little black
and white object ride seaweed braided
around a bird's breast bone a petrol
because they ride the storm onyx said
shamed face the princess bowed her
unseen head and murmured thanks and
kargish the fetish disappeared within
her veils and so this is her
accepting
being part of a culture that she felt
totally
afraid of and separated from
as well
finally
we have something even bigger
happening on the
voyage
this is changing the
very status of things
so they may see roque island soon this
is lebanon talking with the princess
and when they had gained this tiny haven
where they're visible to the rest of the
ship but they could turn their backs on
it as much privacy as royalty can hope
for
the princess turned to him
and pushed back the veil from her face
he had intended to ask what he could do
for her but the question seemed both
inadequate and irrelevant he said
nothing
she said lord king in her at her i am
fayagat in roque island i am to be
king's daughter of car god to be this i
am not fire god i am bare face if it
please you
after a moment he said yes yes princess
this is this is well done
it please you
very much yes i thank you princess
bharara zoo she said a regal acceptance
of thanks her dignity abashed him her
face had been flaming red when she first
put back the veil there was no color in
it now but she stood straight and still
and gathered up her forces
for another speech and here she tells
them about the verdurnun which is going
to be very instrumental in figuring out
what's going on but
burying her face choosing to go
without the veils is also
you know overcoming her fears and
demonstrating courage
the final thing that we have to
discuss is
the ending of the story
in which you know as cecirac says
oh my friend she's talking to tener what
will happen to us the dead are coming
here do you feel them like the tide
rising across that wall i think nobody
can stop them all the dead people from
the graves of all the islands of the
west all the centuries
and a little bit later when everybody
else is going to be going off to try to
break the wall
um cecil hack says
what do we do
they are all gone on the dragon's way
what are we to do tenor
and tenor says
we are to keep the house
cesaro drops to her knees she'd seen
lebanon lying near the doorway stretched
face down in the grass he isn't dead i
think oh my dear lord king don't go
don't die and tenor says
he's with them stay with him
keep him warm keep the house cesaro and
that's that's the only way in which she
can do her duty the perform the courage
is to do something that is an action
that is also awaiting and what we find
just a little bit later
is that
here we go
um
she she's crouching beside lebron in her
arms across him protecting him
daring any wizard to touch him her eyes
flashed she held lebanon short steel
dagger naked in her hand
and uh oswar says you know to to her
ghanai her title and kargash her eyes
flashed up to him oh me
will i be thanked and the mother praised
forever lord ozr make these accursed
sorcerers go away kill them they have
killed my king she held out her dagger
to him by its slender steel blade no
princess he went with the dragon irian
but this sorcerer brought him back to us
let me see him he's cold it was a hard
way back take him in your arms princess
keep him warm and that is what she does
and he does come back to life and we
find at the very end
that they are
married this is in tenor's own words um
there is a council meeting
the king's council for the betrothal
there will be a grand wedding
but they were truly married already with
alpharon's ring
our ring and she recounts lebanon came
and stood here see on my left then
cesaro came and stood here on my right
in front of morin's throne i held up the
ring the way i did when we brought it to
havnor remember and look far in the
sunlight lebron and took it in his hands
and kissed it and gave it back to me and
i put it on her arm it just went over
her hand she's not a little woman cecil
rock oh you should see her gad what a
beauty she is what a lion he's met his
match and everyone shouted and there
were festivals and so on and so i could
get away and so they are brought
together in you know part because their
relationship has completely
transformed she is now no longer just a
pawn in a game that's being played
between kings but rather the partner
and the lover of the king and his equal
through
her courage
you